son neuvième et dernier album s'appelle
9,9 comme le chiffre 9 comme tout neuf
un seul mot pour deux idées alain
chamfort cultive l'ambiguïté même
l'ambivalence guettait l'image elle
bouge
éric perrin dit des dames
il fait partie de ces chanteurs qui
savent inventer des ambiances où il fait
bon se lovait les chansons d'amour
toujours empreinte de passion alain
chamfort se sentent à l'aise dans les
mélodies chaloupées et romantique sur
lesquels jacques duval dépose des textes
subtils
seul en scène avec steven yves piat nist
fantasque et fantastique chamfort veut
rencontrer son public d'une façon plus
intimiste nouvelles et anciennes
chansons à quatre mains sur deux
claviers ça permet de redécouvrir les
chansons de d'aller à l'essentiel de ce
que sont les chansons d'hier mélodies
texte et puis et puis malgré tout cet
accompagnement fou quoi inattendue qui
qui nous entraîne dans une dimension
autre
l'autre dimension alain chamfort c'est
aussi flirté avec dans ses vidéoclips
l'ennemi dans la glace réalisé par jean
baptiste mondino
ou quand la prouesse technique se met au
service de la poésie
je me souviens de leur que j' étais
un traître la fedis par elle
et moi qui chaussures
chasseur ou chaque scène qu'est ce qui
s'est passé
où
dans la glace ton programme
oui mais je connais
dans la glace ton regard
me veut pas
bien
quand les jambes croisées qui me font
part du fait qu'ils apprécient mon
travail ça me donne vraiment c'est ça
qui avec des petits moments comme ça
qu'on a envie de continuer
chaque soin
oublié le temps du chanteur à midinettes
alain chamfort c'est le romantisme sans
la mièvrerie ses mélodies sont à l'image
de sa quarantaine rayonnante